ragazzi non so quanto questo video possa
essere considerato friendly ma in realtà
perché si chiama body hiding simulator
che non dovrebbe essere nulla di strano
però di nascondere dei corpi però vedo
che non è niente di troppo
vedo che una bella giornata hanno quello
non è il sole la luce della camera
riflessa con una grafica che veramente
la mia invidia rtx si sta suicidando
ragazzi non vi aspettate cyberpunk
perché credo che questo gioco non sia
proprio di quella core ha bisogno o
salve c'è del gioco in questa qualità
comunque lei aumento molto grosso e io
le posso camminare addosso per farla
indietreggiare questa è una bellissima
cosa mi parlano cosa ha detto al mister
muscolo
c'è un uomo nudo in casa mia mi scusi
scusi viscusi ausilio scritto sotto cosa
devo fare ce l'avevo l'obiettivo ci stia
qua che le vado a prendere una
buonissima soda anzi eccola qua e là
offro subito tenga le piace
adesso le vado a prendere un'altra sia
qui è mamma mia allora c'è un modo per
farlo se non con questo perfetto a si
può lanciare perfetto non faccia casa al
coltello che appena uscito viscusi me lo
tiene un secondo a 20 mia moglie
arriverà il 7 secondi obiettivo aspetto
atleta come lo descrivo un uomo nudo in
canon nonché tanto che sia morto picanto
che c'è un uomo nudo nell'armadio abrial
mario abbia armadio con la musica di
dovrebbe essere mia moglie è questa e
non si apre l'armadio non hanno fatto le
porte che si aprono il gioco list da
schifo questo non ci sono le porte che
si aprono perché un gioco non troppo
elaborato a quanto pare che non l'avrei
mai detto che strano ma moglie aspetta
non so come dove lo nascondo
non so dove nasco arriva in dieci
secondi aspetta aspetta aspetta il
cuscino di cui ci metti o sotto i
cuscini
ma perché non si vede e non si vede
perfetto tesoro non si vede potrebbe
essere così
questa è mia moglie è proprio lei amore
non sei come ti ricordavo sei molto più
muscolosa e perché non mi leggi questo
tesoro mentre vado a controllare tutti
mi scusi niente l'ho uccisa anche lei va
beh sai quanta gente nuda c'è in casa
mia occhio porca vacca quello dove sta
andando al cesso ragazzi non capisco
perché c'è tutta sta gente qua nuda a
casa mia
potreste andare a casa vostra per farne
un'area è entrato uno blu e questo da me
mi sono cagato addosso questo era un
jump square entrato un tizio blu qua e
lei è autorizzato entrare in casa mia
che tratta di non conosco casa mia mi
scusi disco doveva domanda c'era un tipo
blu l'ho visto ho visto un tipo più che
correva in sala ma dov'è finito
house band arriving in otto secondo me
era quindi non è la mia moglie quali
sopra sarah lane e ha per caso visto un
tipo blu che correva nell'altra stati ho
visto un tipo blu prima è sparito c'era
un tipo blu va bene eccolo dove stai
andando dove sei andato prima ma sei
uscito subito dopo
porca vacca cio non riesco uccido vieni
qua vacche gioco è fatto tutti i giochi
della mia vita cosa mi sono cosa cos'è
questa roba vi prego datemi room on ice
snow aver chiesto giocata sta cosa come
si nascondono i corpi dove si cosa si
apre in questa casa per nascondere i
corpi niente si sa ma hiding baudis 1995
non puoi nascondere i corpi estranei sta
roba buongiorno lei aumento grosso mi
tengono e vabbè un vaso può ammazzare la
gente allora siamo tutti persone letali
ma pure se ti lancio la soda mori a
questo andato liscio previsto e questo
forse queste blu perché mia moglie e può
essere diverso da quelli di prima
tesoro vieni qua teso amore sei tu mia
moglie palesati sapete qual è la colonna
sono la giusta lo sapete tutti
tira
ragazzi io non credo di poter giocare
ulteriormente a questa e non perché è un
gioco niente ma cosa stupida vieni un
cestino thor e ga tanto questi non
muoiono questi si rilanci un vaso
muoiono e questo è l'altro nave di game
over ho perso perché non so spiegare
perché grazie body hi se volete il 1995
che la mia data di nascita e non capisco
il perché sia 1995 però gran gioco
ragazzi gran gioco va bè ragazzi siamo
sul web de golf per completare
completezza ormai questo gioco lo uso un
po come completezza visto che va bene su
qualsiasi cosa puoi fare un po di
streamer challenge che non ho mai fatto
però so che chi fa streaming può provare
a fare lo streaming challenge questa è
veramente difficile ed è fatto per
l'east river buona fortuna va bene
magari dovevo ricordarmi un attimo che
tipo di gioco in realtà e water golf
però va beh posso comunque farcela
porca vacca l'obiettivo per chi non lo
sapesse è comunque un gioco che anche
senza un po come l'altro è quindi non ne
ha
[Musica]
stiamo dicendo
l'obiettivo è quello di arrivare alla
buca con un classico gioco di gotti
problema che non è proprio classico
non so se ve ne siete accorti porca
vacca è veramente difficile allora ok
la partenza è buona very good e vabbè
piano piano zio piano perché se non
riesce ad arrivare alla bandiera dopo un
catino e va bene no devi andare molto
più piano fra te e non lo so lo so non è
facile però vabbè ce la faremo ce la
faremo bellissimo ce l'ho fatta you got
golf ed è così che è successo con la
macchina va bene
borja vacca ok questa non me l'aspettavo
raga questa veramente fighissimo lei
credo che l'essere merciale ci siano
veramente [ __ ] anche perché comunque
non ho finito totalmente la campagna di
questo gioco vinci saranno rob è
completamente inaspettate quindi devo
arrivare alla fine entro un tot e ritiri
immagino ok perfetto
porca vacca c'era una scorciatoia
bellissimo
carpe diem c'è poi vi devo confrontare
con gli altri player per vedere come
quanto sto facendo questo lancio la
pallina lancio nello quello di lanciare
me stesso è stata pallina non certo a
noi la freccia datevi sta contando i
tiri perché poi vi mette in classifica
con gli altri c'è proprio un malati
koivisto gioco ok ma questo è buono
questo è buono capitan sparrow
va bene sono la pecora qua non la casa
fa cose che sto vedendo come sono la
casa devo andare
immagino lì a destra immagino che
passano di qua e ci mette molto meno
tempo però ormai ho fatto 50 tv il primo
degli stream era la fatto molto meno
occupare
poi non so magari mi sbaglio io
ok dove la bandiera eccola qua non puoi
fare figli un top ten normale ma te ne
servono almeno una decina
l'ultimo posso farlo bene non ti posso
farlo bene
no no che schifo flag bandiera 57 ho
fatto quanto so che questo è un attacco
alla pallina ti prego niente sto gioco
di golf la pallina non va usata mai
madonna vogliono tener prende un
esplosivo in più dove era nato a nava è
lontanissimo alla bandiera non cercherò
mai
solo io so no no ragazzi qua non posso
morire ve lo assicuro perchè ci metto
otto ore qua per ripartire ci metto 8
ore vi prego fatemi chiesto livello come
ha fatto la censura quello per lancia
come barile
come ha fatto la gente a sopravvivere al
suo livello impossibile donna se vabbè
dai radio ciao non ce la farò mai
porca vacca che sveglia mi fate finire
sto livello per cortesia per favore
quanto cibo o questa è l'anti non
colpire non colpi e bravo questa non
tiro decente finalmente occhio occhio
porco demonio porco 91 ci sto passando
la mia vita su stoner e il locale alla
meglio body hiding ma porca vacca
no no ce n'è uno ce n'è uno ce n'era uno
e sono pure caduto ma no che è posto a
posto perché sei caduto giù saliamo
ammazzato la mente sali sali su questa
fare per cortesia e niente non mi sale a
quanto ci vuole per finire un livello
otto ore non preto ammazzo
no no che palle
dai ragazzi basta che fa
lenovo veramente non so dove la guarda
se non mi ammazzo adesso ve lo giuro
pasta madonna allora mi è veramente ci
devo venire a prendere badilate sui
denti ci spiegano i ragazzi concluderò
questo video qua
spero che il video di sia
[Musica]